el gobierno de israel está en jaque por
cuarta vez en dos años
la inusual coalición formada en abril
por los dos principales partidos no
alcanzó un acuerdo sobre los
presupuestos por lo que los israelíes
irán a las urnas nuevamente el 23 de
marzo no ha sido posible llegar a un
acuerdo para evitar otras elecciones por
lo que habilitamos a los miembros de la
cámara a ejercer el mandato que nos ha
sido otorgado
estamos ante una difícil campaña así que
llamo a todos los israelíes a mantener
la calma y abstenerse detención
económica
admito no
a ambos partidos el de derecha likud y
el centrista azul y blanco se culparon
mutuamente de la crisis
no hay unidad no tenía ilusiones con
respecto a netanyahu sabía de su
historial como violador de promesas en
serie
estamos en contra de las elecciones es
una decisión incorrecta por parte del
partido azul y blanco pero si fuerza en
otros comicios prometo que los ganaría
por ejemplo con núcleo
benjamín netanyahu quien ha estado en el
poder desde 1996 permanecerá como primer
ministro hasta que se forme un nuevo
gobierno basado en los resultados de las
elecciones de marzo pero no tiene
asegurado un sexto mandato la aparición
de otros partidos como nueva esperanza
que toman fuerza según encuestas la
posibilidad de un nuevo confinamiento
debido al cob y 19 la llegada del
demócrata joe by the end a la casablanca
o su paso por los tribunales en varios
procesos de corrupción son solo algunos
de sus retos